Speaker 1: Believe it or not, though, there's
even more stupidity out there, this time coming
from not the former people at Fox News like
Bill O'Reilly, but the current people.
On Fox and Friends on Tuesday, Carley Shimkus.
Decided to offer one of the most idiotic takes
on why people should not get the COVID vaccine.
She said this and this was actually they were
talking about the clip of Trump and O'Reilly
because apparently, you know, slow news week
is one of the biggest things.
So she said this.
Good for him.
Everybody should have the option to make up
their own mind about this.
About 74 75 percent of Americans are at least
partially vaccinated.
That's a high number.
If you look at the reality of the situation,
if somebody isn't vaccinated right now and
they look at their two friends who between
the three of them had six shots against COVID
and they still got it because of Omicron,
realistically, that person isn't going to
get vaccinated.
So she's telling people that because you can
still get these breakthrough infections, which,
yes, they're becoming more common.
That you just shouldn't get vaccinated.
Right.
Oh, well, they're vaccinated and they still
got it.
So why would I bother getting vaccinated?
Well, I don't know.
Maybe because those three people aren't dead.
And here's the thing.
We're seeing more breakthrough infections
right now, because as I mentioned earlier
in this program, the efficacy of the vaccines
does deteriorate over time.
And unfortunately, what we're seeing with
these COVID 19 vaccines, the deterioration
is taking place over the course of about six
to nine months.
You know, relatively quickly.
I mean, that's about the half life that we're
seeing off of these vaccines.
So let me read I went through, I compiled
a bunch of statistics here.
So let me read this just to counter her point
that you shouldn't get vaccinated if you're
going to get sick anyway.
One large, ongoing study of 780000 veterans
shows all three vaccines being used in the
U.S. provide strong protection against death
from COVID 19, even as their efficacy against
mild and asymptomatic infection fell off dramatically.
Researchers looking at men and women getting
treatment at Veterans Health Administration
facilities found that overall vaccine efficacy
against all types of infection fell from eighty
seven point nine percent in February to 48
percent in October.
They only counted fully vaccinated veterans,
and these were done via PCR tests.
Unvaccinated patients this is from November,
accounted for 91 percent of COVID 19 deaths
and nearly 94 percent of those with a combined
need for ventilators or death.
That's according to the Journal of American
of the American Medical Association.
Again, from just last month.
So.
Does the vaccine prevent you from getting
sick?
Does it prevent you from having a breakthrough
infection?
Not necessarily.
You are still capable of getting sick even
if you've been vaccinated and boosted at this
point.
Does it reduce your chances of getting sick?
Heck yeah.
Does it reduce your chances of dying from
COVID 19 or even being put on a ventilator?
Oh, double heck, yeah.
That's what these numbers tell us.
Ninety one percent of deaths are unvaccinated.
94 percent of deaths slash people on ventilators.
Unvaccinated.
So if getting these shots knocks you down.
Into a less than 10 percent chance.
Of being one of the people who die from this
disease, would you not take that?
Would you not accept that risk when you know
what's waiting on the other side?
And that is the part that people like Carley
Shimkus conveniently leave out of their arguments.
You know, oh, well, people can still get sick.
Sure, they can still get sick.
You can still get the flu, even if you've
had a flu shot.
But you're less likely to get it as severe
if you've had the vaccine, and it's the same
thing with COVID.
What we're trying to do with the moment, in
addition to slow the spread, which, let's
face it, as a country, we're really, really
bad at that.
We're trying to prevent more deaths.
We're trying to prevent long term injury,
you know, the long haulers they call them.
I have some in my family.
That had covered months ago.
They still can't even climb a flight of stairs
without getting winded and having to sit down.
We don't know yet how severely this virus
is going to continue to impact people year
after year.
And I'm not just talking about new waves and
new infections and talking about the people
who had the severe cases.
And in the case of my family, they didn't
end up on ventilators.
Luckily, they didn't get that far.
So this was just hospitalization from a severe
case that didn't quite get as severe as some
others.
And this story is not unique.
New Orleans Saints coach Sean Payton.
It took him over two months to get over his
COVID infection in the early part of last
year.
And, of course, he recently was re diagnosed
with COVID again.
But we're seeing these long haulers, the people
with these long term issues.
And we don't even have enough time yet under
our belts to fully understand how bad it is
going to affect these people.
Is it going to wear off in about a year the
effects of this, they'll be back to normal?
Or is this going to be a persistent problem
that opens them up to other breathing complications
in the future, other lung ailments?
We don't know yet.
So for all those people out there who say,
Oh, well, we don't know what's in the vaccines,
you don't know what's in Mountain Dew either,
but you have no problem guzzling that down.
But more importantly, you don't know what
the long term effects of COVID are going to
be on your body.
And I think it's a heck of a lot safer to
trust these vaccines than to trust that this
virus isn't either going to kill you or permanently
damage your lungs to where your life is forever
altered.
I think that's a pretty easy gamble to take
on the vaccines.
I am Farron Cousins in4 David Pakman, you
can find me on social media, Twitter, Facebook,
Instagram at fair and balanced.
We'll be right back.